I actually got a job.
Really?
A job?
You will work Monday to Friday 9:00 to 3:00.
You won't regret, for a moment, hiring me.
Excellent.
Ah, the curse of the summer people.
They dangle their money around to make us do whatever they want.
Joanie Williams,...
...can I see you tomorrow?
I wish you lots of luck, Bobby Marks, and I'll be back in a few weeks.
Hey, what are you doing?
I'm up here!
You sure everything's okay with you?
I'm not a kid anymore.
You'll tell me if it wasn't, wouldn't you?
Have you ever been bullied?
Yes, by some of the best.
Seems like all my problems are caused by summer people.
Some of the worst.
You leave me alone.
What's a fat kid like you gonna do?
What's going on with mom and dad?
Something's up.
Don't worry about it.
About time you grew up.
Hey, I'm growing up.
The measure of a man is his ability to navigate to a proper shore...
...during the worst of the storm.
Hey, that's pretty good.
I should write that one down.